which is a big difference between the
way hackers perceive the security world
and the way that defenders
perceive disagree the world
unfortunately
if you want to examine somebody's uh
perspective about the world
those that succeed
tend to be right um it's just
it's not necessarily that you know that
they have a better opinion of the world
or
it's just that what they think seems to
work and unfortunately
what the hackers were doing and still
are doing it seems to work
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i have with me yoshina the
chief
visionary officer and co-founder of
cyber reason
and yes we're going to be talking about
cyber cyber reason is a leader in edr
and next generation anti-virus solutions
for enterprises
eoc is an accomplished software
developer and expert in technology
architecture
machine learning big data analytics and
visualization
during his 20 years of industry
experience usc has designed and built
many products from cutting-edge security
platforms for the defense industry in
israel
to big data platforms his products have
been deployed worldwide and used by
fortune 500 companies on a daily basis
since he founded cybereason in 2012 the
company raised almost 400 million
dollars from investors like softbank
lockheed martin crv and spark capital
cyber reason is privately held with 700
employees
operates in 40 countries and
headquartered in boston with offices in
london
tel aviv and tokyo yo welcome to 20
minute leaders
chief visionary officer and co-founder
of cyber reason
welcome to my show how are you today
good good uh so it's lovely to be here
so it's a great time around central
israel the sun is about to set
perhaps even during during our call so
the the lighting will change a bit but i
but i'm really excited to take you this
opportunity in these 20 minutes to
reflect a little bit about your journey
and about your understanding
and you know in the cyber security space
but even beyond the cyber security space
how you got into this space originally
studied economics and physics
uh you you've done quite a few things
throughout your career
and on the engineering side on the
research side and so i'm
i'm looking forward to hearing a little
bit about yourself and and then
talking a little bit more broadly about
cyber security as a domain
and and where we're headed and the more
the visionary part so you'll see
take me back a little bit throughout
your journey and how how would you
look at your journey if you had to
reflect back
well i think that um
my journey really started i think
my first i don't know before i into
computers
i was in um yeah probably around middle
school
it was a sixth seventh grade when i had
my first
computer and got a little bit into
computer programming when i was
13 14 i think anybody that uh
what what year what year is um
94 or 95 probably
93. wow so just when the internet is
really starting yeah
it was a really interesting time it was
kind of the
i was still a little bit into the bbs
scene
i don't know if you know what that is um
so before the internet there were these
uh basically
call-in numbers that you could dial with
the modem and you can
log in and it's got a text-based
interface where you could do
stuff you could download stuff you could
play online games
um but within like a small community
there were like networks of bbs's it was
like this whole thing
um it was completely replaced of course
with uh with the internet when when that
came in
this way first with forums and irc and
like a bunch of other stuff
and when when i was kind of
getting started i was i think 16 or 17
when i first started connecting to the
internet i think that
everybody from my my generation
everybody who uh
who was involved in software and
programming you always have
kind of an eye on security it's it's
it's an inseparable part of
what you do and there's always these
viruses going around
just to announce on the radio that
today's michelangelo's birthday so turn
off your computers because there's like
the michelangelo virus that would
they would delete everything wow and um
that is so cool well of course the word
i would use to describe it but
um but that was it was a very different
time in terms of
the the idea of somebody remotely
hacking your computer
didn't really exist there were a lot of
worms that that would go around there
was like the
lavi virus i think it was 2001 or so
it was like a uh email worm that would
just spread like crazy and did like a
ton of damage all of computers
but this was what this was what was
security at the time
it was that it was freaking which is you
know hacking into phones
and if you ever watched uh the movie
hackers
uh but that that kind of is it's a
it's a movie from the 90s uh with
angelina jolie that
just kind of gives you a feel of like
the concept of
what hacker culture was at the time um
you know hacking was was something that
you do with these old computers into
into these little networks that you
would dial into and
the whole concept of the internet and it
really
it really goes back to to those days and
and the love of this
of this world i think stems from that
not to say that i was particularly into
hacking
i'm more of a maker i like to build
things so
for me this was really always about
about creating things
and that's that's what i used to do for
the first few years
uh or maybe for the first 20 years not
not so
few when i when i decided to go back
well
i kind of i was always into into
building things i was building software
um and there was a time in my life where
i wanted to explore other things
so you know you mentioned um a little
bit of my background so
i kind of wanted to know because i've
been in computers for so long
and because i've been building software
for so long and from a relatively young
age it was always kind of like
you know this is where my life is going
but i wanted to know if um
if it's a choice that i'm making or if
it's kind of rolling by default into
something
so i when i went to school i decided i'm
gonna try
um i'm gonna try physics which is
something i always enjoyed
and um when i did that for a little bit
and then i went for economics for a
little bit i worked for the central bank
um one of my professors was uh
was a manager of one of the departments
and
he was looking for people so i was there
for a while
um it was an interesting journey you
know you learn
i think the most when you go to these
places
that you really have no idea what
they're about
um and they're very very far from the
world that you're used to so
i think there's nothing further than uh
you know the typical high-tech company
than you know going into the central
bank and seeing the way that life is
there and the way the work
goes on there understanding the internal
politics of
of a complex organization like that it
gives you a lot of
insight after when when you work with
these organizations when i
when i was working for this services
company which which was kind of my
my more real entry into cyber security
i was working for this company called
the gita that
did cyber security services or really
development services but we're more
security oriented
so i worked a lot with the defense
industry here in israel
during that time and i i've
i've learned i've had this idea of how
these big organizations work so when you
come to
to work with them you have to understand
that time has a different meaning
uh in this in these places and work life
is is a really different thing than what
you're used to when you work for a tech
company
you know there's no time when you work
for a tech company you always feel like
the future is burning and you're always
behind and you have competitors and
you kind of have to to do everything as
quickly
as you can and in these places right
time time is very flexible
time is flexible very different and you
think you also think you know in years i
was working on a project that it's
it's like lifetime was supposed to be
like five years
i was working on a project for building
a security system for a bank
they were i don't know year six into the
project when i joined
it it was supposed to be over you know
about a year or two before that
uh and it continued long after i left at
that
particular services company so
that was kind of my entry into into the
cyber security world
it was always something that i found to
be interesting there are a lot of
interesting problems
uh there and i have a close friend of
mine jonathan
who's my co-founder um
we've been friends since high school
we've always talked about you know let's
start a company sort of coming in
i think all the stars kind of aligned
and we met lior and
it created this really amazing
connection between the three of us
uh the top build this company so it was
it was kind of
will and timing and um
and luck you know you always need luck
so co-founder and chief revenue officer
of of cyber register
uh revenues visionary yes problem
no no apology is a visionary yes of
course because that that is you know
that that is an awesome title and we
started this podcast
by mentioning that you know i want to
understand a little bit
you know your your own vision and your
own perspective on
on what does this mean on what is the
cyber security space you choose to
to create a company once you once you
get introduced into the space
what does cyber reason do how does it
integrate into the greater scope of how
cyber security is
in your mind well i think that
when we entered the market um we
understood
before we started it there's a problem
of perception
there's a big gap between the way
hackers think and we were in the hacking
world
in different ways uh for a long time
um it is a big difference between the
way hackers perceive
the security world and the way that
defenders perceive the secret world
unfortunately if you want to examine
somebody's
uh perspective about the world those
that succeed
tend to be right um it's just
it's not necessarily that you know that
they have a better opinion of the world
or
it's just that what they think seems to
work and unfortunately
what the hackers were doing and still
are doing it seems to work
um and unfortunately the the kind of
opposite side of it is that it means
that what the rest of us are doing
and it has to do with the cyber security
company
and defenders in general and governments
the way that we think
about the world of computers in the
world of hacking
is very very different when you look
when you look at it from a defender's
perspective than from an attacker's
perspective
but if the but if the attackers keep
winning
probably you need to look a little bit
of their perception of the world
and the first question we ask is kind of
what is there
we have two main important questions is
what is
what are they afraid of um
which which was a key questions for a
question for us
because it was like okay if i could
understand the things that
were that attackers worry about if i
could do those things
i'd probably have a better chance of
stopping them
the other thing was what advantage do i
have
because it seemed like i had no
advantage i had all these systems that i
have to constantly patch
i have all these systems to configure
just configure them in some optimal way
they have to be on top of everything all
the time and that still doesn't help me
because
somebody has left a vulnerability in my
my
outlook exchange server and then you
know i'm owned
and you know now we'll do it
right so so where's the advantage so
these are these are key questions
so what are what hackers are afraid of
we we just went we
we asked our hacker friends the people
that you know do this for a living and
do this in the military
and they told us about every time that
some some new security thing came along
they usually weren't very concerned
nobody cares about your anti-virus
they can test them they can they can
verify exactly how they work
computers are you know despite
a lot of myths computers are incredibly
predictable systems
and so we you can if you if you put into
time
understand exactly what they do and how
they work
it gives you a massive advantage when
you try to penetrate someone you have
all the time in the world you can you
know set up
a whole mock operation build up
you know even a nuclear
refining facility simulate it and then
and then attack it and you don't even
have to be there you can build a program
that's going to do it automatically for
you
that's how predictable this world is um
wow so this is this isn't really
something you can do anywhere else right
right and i love the reference of course
um you know you can see how hard it is
to work in the predictable real world
the real world is incredibly complicated
which is why you know it's been
it's taken years of very very smart
people building on the work of very
smart people to
just try to build you know self uh
driving cars it's
it's a really really complicated
technology the autonomy of cars doing
around in the world
not i'm not saying for a car to uh to
decide to do something or you know to
try to crash into people or whatever
just for a car to drive to be able to
understand the world around
and and now you can on the other hand
you can build a piece of software that
will infiltrate and move from one
computer to another in a complex network
get to a management system and perform a
covert operation
that will you know accelerate and slow
down centrifuges in a way that will make
them break and do that for so long
without anybody understanding that
that's what's going on
i mean there is no equivalent to this in
the real world
and it's just because this world
is so foreign to us but the people that
that you know
run hacking operations they think about
it
it's kind of how can i get in what are
the ways that i have
once i'm in how can i do something you
know covertly so that i can reach you
know whatever it is i'm trying to do
still their data ruined their
centrifuges
you know shot off their gas with
accidentally with the ransomware
um as you know it just happened
these are kind of i mean it's kind of
crazy that it's
possible to do all these things and that
they can be done
not only covertly but with no
attribution
so even if somebody that somebody
notices
uh catching whoever was involved is
incredibly difficult
so it gives a lot of cover it gives a
lot of possibility to the people on the
other side
they're not really afraid of getting
caught and if you run upset
properly then you probably want to be
caught
so so we asked them what they're afraid
of
what on the network worries them what
thing that happened on a computer
and the question the answer that kept
coming back is that
they do really don't want to be noticed
they don't want anybody paying attention
to what they're doing
and the thing is that the things that
are looking they're trying to look for
specific bad things that are going on
that's that's not a very effective way
because computers are predictable
systems if i can anticipate what you're
going to do
i've won you know it's just like in
chess if i know your next move
i've won because i can do something
to prepare before you can you can think
about that
so it's kind of a one-sided chess game
because you know one side is playing
chess which is the hackers on the other
side is
i don't know playing remy cube or
whatever they're playing a different
game
they don't understand the game that
they're in
now from from that perspective we came
and said okay what advantage do i have
and the advantage the defender has is
that they own the battlefield
they don't need to take over it but they
don't have the power
of leveraging that fact you know
they need visibility they need to to to
get hold of their
of the battlefield they need to own it
they need to be able to understand
you know imagine if i came into your
house and i was walking around your
house
and you couldn't see me i was invisible
to you
and i would move things around and it
you'd be completely unaware of the fact
that it's going
this is how most networks are i can go
into your
personal computer i can move stuff
around and you just
won't have any idea that i'm there so
we're trying to create
some to bring something of that physical
equivalence into this virtual world
where
there would not be no way for you to do
something on
my device without me knowing about it
and then
on that we built the abilities to
behaviorally understand what
good what normal people do what hackers
do
a little bit of anomaly detection a
little bit of artificial intelligence
that go into that
and a lot of human intelligence of
people that
we built this uh this graph system so
that all our technology is proprietary
and
i won't go into that because we're not a
very i don't think it's a very technical
show
um but the the base
concept of it is to try and translate
the way that
human incident responders and defenders
the best of them
think and approach investigation
give them the best tools and automate as
much of the work as possible
to help them detect and then very
quickly resolve
and it works it really does because
we've shifted the way that we think
from thinking about how to stop somebody
from getting in
but rather to understand what they're
doing when they're what once they're
inside
and and that is really the key
use your advantage make sure that you
have a hold of the battlefield and
leverage that to defend
what 100 and i think that you're the way
that you're looking at this
this industry is is really interesting
to me coming from the industry myself
and
and being on both sides it's it's an
interesting perspective i think also you
you touched a little bit on the
psychology and you touched a little bit
about about
about behavior and at the end of the day
this is behavior that we're not used to
do
and you know people investigating these
types of things is not something that
that we've been practicing for many many
years it's something that is
continuously evolving
one of the things that we're obviously
referencing also in this cat and mouse
game the mouse is always first
the mouse always starts running and then
and then the cat starts chasing and
and and it you know as you become more
and more
um you know once you become more and
more flexible and as you become more and
more alert
obviously the things change and and i
think this is what that's the beauty
also of this industry
and this cat and mouse game and you'll
see i really want to thank you for
for coming here in 20 very short minutes
but but i still learned so much and i
really appreciate it
i have three questions that are not
related to what we talked about
and they're not committing either but
i'm really curious to hear
a little bit about you if you're upset
going back to middle school what what
fascinated you as a kid what was your
favorite subject
um well you know it's it's these
these kind of questions that um that
give me pause sometimes because you feel
like
sometimes you feel like you know in our
culture that you can you can shrink the
complex uh
state of being for somebody to to this
very very narrow
fact about them oh i liked a lot of
things
i liked a lot of things i really liked
computers which is kind of
why i'm doing what i'm doing but i liked
even before the internet yeah but i
liked physics i liked music
i liked people and i still do i still
like all of these things amazing
keep person or people throughout your
journey that inspired you
personally or professionally
i think i've i've met a lot of people on
the way you know there were
there were teachers that were
significant to me and kind of helped me
learn things
and i also did a lot you know on my own
i spent a lot of time you know learning
and studying
but i think in recent years i found that
there are certain people that i can lean
on and that i can work with
and that can really help me evolve you
know as a human as a person
uh not just you know professionally and
and and really helped me change my
perspective about the world
right i think and you know going back to
you know
the look on these questions uh the three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
if you're up for it i i definitely i i
you know just from this conversation i
can feel that it would be impossible to
classify
in three words we touched on so many
subjects that obviously fascinate you
and show who you are but if there were
three words
that you would think describe you
your personality who you are um
well i'll i'll tell you what i think
other people would say because
i i don't really classify myself in that
way
but i think most people that know me
would probably first say that i'm
very intelligent warm
and sensitive
i love it you'll see thank you for
spending this time with me this was
wonderful
thank you stay safe stay healthy thank
you for the inspiration thank you
pleasure
you